New York City has just erected a golden
demon statue on top of a courthouse near
Madison Square Park and when I say a
golden demon statue I'm not being
hyperbolic or funny it is a gold statue
of a demon woman with horns on her head
and weird tentacle things for arms
dedicated to Ruth Bader Ginsburg and
specifically to ginsburg's support for
abortion the artist who made it told the
New York Times that the statue is part
of a quote
urgent and necessary cultural Reckoning
underway as New York reconsiders
traditional representations of power in
public spaces and recast Civic
structures to better reflect 21st
century mores the libs and the artists
see this as a wonderful thing the horns
on the Beast are according to the
reports meant to symbolize autonomy and
sovereignty nice enough sounding values
and at least until you think about what
they really mean but that is how it
always goes